hello and welcome to a dramatic reading  of text messages sent to mark meadows  from jenny thomas help this great  president stand firm mark you are the  leader  with him who is standing for america's  constitutional governance at the  precipice  the majority knows biden in the left is  attempting the greatest heist  of our history sounds like sydney and  her team are getting inundated with  evidence of fraud make a plan release  the kraken and save us from the left  taking america down i can't see  americans swallowing the obvious fraud  just going with one more thing with no  freaking consequences  the whole coup and now this  we just cave to people wanting biden to  be anointed  many of us can continue the gop charade  and this has been a dramatic reading of  text messages sent to mark meadows from  jenny thomas